Even if Grant makes 0 glasses wipers, we know that he's going to have to pay
$1,200 for rent each month. So, his expenses are going to start at $1,200 and
they continue to increase incrementally for each wiper set he produces. So, we
need to include both of these pieces of information in our equation. That means,
that this answer choice, 6.5 times number of glasses wiper sets made, can't be
right because it doesn't account for the monthly rent. The first choice here is
actually not right either because this is saying that for every glasses wiper
set that Grant makes, he'll pay $1,200. That would be pretty unfortunate for
him, that would be a very, very expensive wiper business. And we also know that
it costs $6.50 not $1,200 to make each wiper set. That leaves us with two more
choices, both of which include 1,200 and 6.5 times the number of glasses wipers
made. The difference between these is the sign here. If we pick this third
answer choice right here, we'll be seeing that Grant's monthly expenses decrease
because of this negative sign right here. Decrease for every glasses wiper sets
he makes. This would mean that he would actually be making money off of paying
for materials, which doesn't really make sense. That means this answer choice
isn't right either. The last one is correct. Grant will spend a fixed amount of
$1,200 and then, on top of that, he will spend $6.50 for every wiper set he
made.